okay let's hear from a few more people
via discord davidpakman.com
discord if you'd like to chat with me um
let's go
uh next to
um let's go to bob
from colorado bob from colorado you're
on hey dave how you doing i'm doing well
yeah so i got a question i've been
seeing
news reports recently that um
you see a lot of the maga people
basically accidentally supporting
liberal policies
um
like i saw recently that
i for exactly what it was but there were
attempts to break up uh tech monopolies
like facebook and twitter
and it had uh bipartisan support from
both the left and
a lot of the mega people yep
do you think
we might end up seeing a lot of
accidental liberal policies
kind of from
i don't want to say out of ignorance but
kind of out of ignorance yes i mean
what's going on is
a lot of these maga people are going
against their stated principles just
because they want to own the libs or
companies they perceive to be on the
left so for example like all these maga
people are like regulations bad
um let's not regulate companies but then
like facebook bans their favorite
conservative anti-vaxxer and all of a
sudden they go
uh oh oh uh we gotta regulate that we
gotta regulate we got to regulate
facebook all of a sudden um so uh i
think that at the end of the day they
don't really have an interest in
regulating companies they don't really
have an interest in enforcing antitrust
they've not expressed any interest in
that and i think what's going to stop a
lot of this stuff from becoming
legislation is if they get close to
saying we're going to pass a more robust
antitrust infrastructure to break up
some of these tech companies their big
funders in the corporate world will say
hey if you do that it will also affect
us and then they'll back off of it
that's my prediction
so you don't think we're going to see
any big changes i really don't know
not if it depends on the mega people
like if politics get realigned then yes
but not not thanks to the maga people
okay and one more question um how do you
feel about the right to repair uh
i guess movement or bills that are path
that are going on right now and do you
think we're gonna see anything
positive come out of that i am hopeful i
generally favor right to repair which
relates to a lot of different issues
including intellectual property and and
some other things generally speaking i
favor right to repair but on any
particular bill you know i have to look
at the bill to say for sure
there definitely seems to be bipartisan
support for that as well because i know
a lot of um rural farmers and the like
um are supporting that
to you know be able to fix equipment and
all that yes absolutely yep no i think
it's a it's a worthwhile movement
okay thank you dave you answered all my
questions today all right thank you very
much there's uh there's bob great to
hear from bob
let's go next to
uh is it cedo from spain sado from spain
uh yes hello
uh can you hear me yes i can
hi uh
nice to meet you uh yeah it's so
uh yeah i wanted to ask a question but
i'd like to give a little bit of context
before so you guys can see where i'm
coming from
because seeing the lobby i might be the
only one not from the us right now
that's fine we just want a direct path
to your question you know we try to
avoid two monologues that are too
extensive
yeah uh basically i just wanted to say
that uh in spain uh i don't know how
many of you would be familiar with the
political context here but i tend to
tell my american friends a lot that the
right-wing extremists in spain would be
considered communists in the us
basically because a lot of their
propaganda uh turns around the
conservation of the of the social
government right
and it appeals you know to your older
folks and stuff like that and um around
europe you see many perspectives that
really aren't at all what you see in the
political context in the us and uh i
could give more context if you want in
several different issues but i basically
wanted to ask you
like are you aware maybe you as what
your americans call liberal or uh
americans in general
um are you aware of how crazy and toxic
uh your politics are perceived are
perceived overseas
i am very aware of it i mean listen i i
have family in a lot of different
countries and so i am regularly getting
the feedback that american politics are
toxic and insane we also have viewers
you know 20 of our viewers are not in
the united states and so i get emails
all the time from people in denmark or
spain or anywhere saying
it's insane what's going on in the
united states so yes i am very much
aware that this is not normal here
but i i know you are because as you say
you you speak with a lot of people and
you know many international people know
but do you think there is
so to speak a consensus within the
country no i think a lot of people have
no idea certainly there's a lot of
people that have no idea and uh that i
can't answer for them but there's many
people that don't know what's going on
in other countries
yep fair
fair enough i would say it's it it's a
bit interesting from from the european
perspective
i think we see the united states as
being overly focused within itself
whilst the rest of the world
can know a lot about the us every single
country that has its size on the us will
probably be a complete mystery for
americans many americans are completely
self-centered in their news con
consumption for sure okay segal from
spain thank you so much for the call uh
i'm gonna leave you to the crinkly paper
or whatever you've got going on there um
very very much appreciated let's go next
where do we go next because there's just
it's it's
it's crazy what's happening on the
phones right now if you if you saw what
was happening on the phones
you would be uh
you would be shocked